bill if you could pick five books that
you would be allowed to read every year
and only those five books what would
they be there was a library police and
they said I'm allowing you five and
that's it god I love books I'm just
trying to five yeah sorry I know that's
limiting an empire of their own seen
Empire of their own what's the book I
always talk about in 1984 but the one
would that about the mythology
Jeanne Yurman was his husband and all
the major student all the major guys
read this book hero with a thousand
faces
that's an incredible incredible book
about all the stories of the world have
a certain commonality no matter what
they are Steven Spielberg use it
Lucas it uses it everybody all use it
the hero's journey what is the hero's
journey and there's a commonality to
every single hero's journey I read a
book by Steven Pressfield recently that
every as often as I can and it's called
a war of art it's a take-off on Sun
Tzu's the art of war and it talks about
what is what what is it that stops the
average person from accomplishing
anything they want to accomplish
countless the book is this thick and the
book pisses you off so bad because from
the first page you say to yourself he's
talking about a and he says the father
and mother of incompetence is
procrastination in the rationalizations
we come up with to justify a
procrastination hours and days of
thinking why we're not doing it and
justifying it instead of doing it
he says it's easier to know the hand
that's choking you then to let another
hand in this is motoki Willis you're not
dead
but you asked me to put another you near
me I don't know I don't know this I know
this because that's money it's a
brilliant brilliant going then there are
books forgot the author's name right now
but one is called the dip of them was
called the Purple Cow Seth Godin sinneth
go yeah oh is he great or not here's a
podcast too
he's he's brilliant to him books it is
thick but he tells you and shows you
accomplishment what is accomplishment
that's four and then my favorite poet is
TS Eliot's Four Quartets it's the last
thing well I think before he died he
talks about how every piece of poetry
but before that is meaningless till he
just says right now he talks about what
he's learned in life and puts it
important put it before that Federico
Fellini and Frank Capra - my favorite
directors of all time reading eight and
a half every year I watch and sometimes
look at the script of with mr. Smith
goes to Washington and it's a wonderful
life the message is the the courage that
he had at that time and when he was
tortured by McCarthy for saying he
thinks he said in look he was a big a
communist but he went on and did it
anyway he has encouraged my career and I
can't remember the name of the director
now but the script I could beat over and
over and over again because it's so
brilliant and the film I can watch a
thousand times was it so brilliant came
out around nineteen years ago called Run
Lola Run I've ever seen that one you see
the trailer you gotta watch it I don't
he's a genius
when I say genius he never got the
credit he deserved but the film is
toe pictorially and structurally through
methodologies that no one else has ever
seen done it's that way it's like giving
one example that is except but it's a 20
hour per hour thing this woman is called
by her boyfriend supposed to deliver
drugs to the drug dealer doesn't have
their drugs it set the money to the drug
dealer because he lost the package on
the plane and named drug dealers coming
in like three two or three hours and
he's got to be at a drug store and you
have a pharmacy to meet the drug dealer
if the drug dealer sees now the money
he's gonna get killed so his girlfriend
does everything she can to make sure so
the film is divided in to all the
attempts she makes and it starts her
back at the apartment over and over
again and runs down the steps to
different places now as she runs down
the steps
she must down the steps she's running
doors open to a older lady's apartment
and it moves over the older lady
shoulder into the TV and the TV shows
are here opening down the steps when she
gets in the street she passes people and
everybody she passes you see in five
seconds a flashback of their entire
lives who they are
and when she gets to the place where she
tries to get the money for him and it
fails you go back to the appointment the
phone rings and he says I'm gonna die if
you don't get here she gets up and she
once again to try to get the money from
someplace else
you